newton came up with the theory of
calculus
in quarantine but out of limitations
comes creativity
dr seuss wrote using no more than 50
different words not in a house not with
a mouse
shakespeare wrote king lear in
quarantine necessity is the mother of
invention
comfort is the enemy of progress i love
[Music]
that
it's a nice myth to think of creativity
as an endless open field of
possibilities but the reality is
when people face such a wonderful open
field
they might become paralyzed constraints
are the anchors of creativity
[Music]
the growth of the human brain is by
growing branches by growing branches you
can make more connections and it's by
having connections that you can say aha
now there's an interesting issue over
whether constraints
are actually beneficial or problematic
for
creativity and i think the answer to
both is yes
both cases happens with the case
there's still disagreement at least in
psychology about what creativity really
is
it's people making things that haven't
existed before
everyday elements but putting them
together in a way
not that is just novel but that actually
has a meaning for people that actually
changes the way they see the world
most people tend to think that
creativity is something that
happens to people who have a particular
talent this is a misconception
there is no such thing as a single gene
for
creativity
we can distinguish between two different
types of constraints the intentional
constraint and the unintentional
constraints
these external forces of limitation
and they can be political socioeconomic
being a biracial black female artist
coming from a working class background
could be seen as a limitation within the
art world which
historically has been a very sort of
patriarchal
white middle-class space resilience
comes when you have
problems and challenges and that in turn
gives you ideas
an artist who i very much admire called
faith wringles
wanted to make huge huge canvases in the
same way that a lot of men were making
huge modernist
works of art but she didn't actually
have the space at home to do that
and so she started to make these huge
quilts roll it
up and take it to various galleries
she's a great example
of how an artist can flourish under
limitation
avoid familiarity and embrace novelty be
it using different materials or a
different method or a different
process if you always write poetry
try prose schedule a particular time
when you are going to do nothing else
but
engage in the creative task and that's
one of the ways in which
people with very little time can write
books by telling everybody in your
family that that's what you're going to
be doing
you're actually protecting a space for
yourself for something creative to
happen start drawing and give yourself
five minutes do another drawing give
yourself 10 seconds to do the drawing
when we are given less time to do
something usually the most important
information comes across
if you're playing in a band and you're
getting really really stuck swap
instruments
that can create new ideas in your songs
as well
or paint a red dot or a blue line in the
upper left corner of your blank canvas
and then challenge yourself to
incorporate those constraints into the
composition
and even though you may not end up using
those particular constraints in the
final product
they can be beneficial for creativity as
long as you play around with them
willingly
what might happen is that the mere
experience with playing around with
different
limitations stretches your imagination
and improves creativity
you